you know I had CPA one time years ago
George we had when Ramsey was a small
company it was actually a friend and um
but uh he knew I had gone through
everything losing everything and I was
you know I'm now debt free and I don't
borrow money anymore he came in and he's
kind of
he was kind of going to tell me how
things are kind of going to school me up
a little bit you know and he said so and
you know well you know I don't agree
with you about this whole debt thing and
being debt free and all that but we
don't have to be in agreement about that
for me to do your taxes oh boy or to be
your CPA and I thought yeah actually we
do kind of do you know we kind of a deal
breaker because a CPA who can't do math
is bothersome you know that's just a
problem so I can't I can't do that no
it's not you know we cannot be we can be
friends we can hang out on the weekend
you're not doing my books
there's a big difference it's a
different thing here